holy crap
[Music]
what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we're going to
watch from new rock stars eternals post
credits scenes explained major cameos
and mystery voice confirmed feel like it
was pretty obvious who the mystery voice
was that they're referring to obviously
i haven't seen eternals please if you
don't want the spell for you don't don't
watch this video and yeah it was one of
those post-credits scenes where i didn't
fully comprehend everything we're gonna
watch it a second time tonight we're
planning on doing a spoiler talk either
on sunday or monday so keep a lookout on
our youtube community page when we deep
dive into it we're gonna see if i like
the movie more the second time around
and if i hate it this time i think it
sucks
either way it's good to learn what new
rockstars has to say because we want to
fully understand what's going on here
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and marvel's eternals post-credits
scenes leave viewers with new highs and
wait what that we haven't felt in years
the kind of twists that can only be
truly appreciated by watching this movie
in a theater so before i explain what
happened in the implications spoiler
warning go watch the movie first trust
me and again another spoiler
okay top headline first yes harry styles
is now in the mcu playing thanos's
brother arrows aka star fox the
implications of his arrival are the real
scoops here and it's a less obvious
cameo in the second post-credits scene
that really blew this mind it is sweeter
than the sweetest watermelon sugar so
let's break it down okay so eternals
ends with cersei stopping the emergence
of the sleeping celestial tiamat
hatching out of our earth and killing us
all by boosting her transfiguration
abilities with the yeah
into marble stone icarus completes his
mythological destiny and flies into the
sun nina and makari depart earth to look
for other eternals cersei turns sprite
into a human and decides to stay on
earth along with kingo and fastos but
then in the final scene ereshim returns
and zips cersei fastos and kingo up into
space and says you have chosen to
sacrifice a celestial for the people of
this planet i will spare them but your
memories will determine if they are
worthy to live and i will return in
judgment and then they all disappear
into a black hole leaving dane whitman
back on earth alone i gotta say i
remember the first time watching that as
much as i was more on the side of the
move you guys know where i'm at but as
much as i was in that camp that ending
moment was like oh that's pretty scary
that's pretty scary yeah score one for
the eternals now the first post-credits
scene picks up with the three in the
domo who worry about their lost contact
with their friends back on earth but
then a little light glimmers in the
corridor and through this portal tumbles
pip the troll voiced by patton oswalt
wait a minute pattern oswald oh yeah i
didn't know that yeah absolutely
that's his voice and and you can kind of
catch the little facial features in that
cgi that everyone's been dogging on is
it he also modoc yes he is the voice of
modoc oh my goodness this is multiversal
madness patton oswalt's sons and he's an
agent of shield as multiple characters
hold on to that john he announces
behold the royal prince of titan brother
of thanos defeater of black robert and
then the guy goes roger he goes oh right
the defender of black roger the great
adventurer star fox and then harry
freaking styles enters as eros aka star
fox and says what a pleasure to make
your acquaintance my fellow eternals you
know you really don't have to do the
whole thing every time i am aeros this
is pip and you are as beautiful as
legend says nina your friends are in big
trouble
and we know where to find them harry
styles improvised that line he's trying
to sleep with angelina jolie
he will
he will be the father to so many adopted
children now and he reveals he has his
own golden sphere to communicate with
the celestials and he flashes a horny
smile cue foreigners feels like the
first time
because theresa's name is arrows and pip
we're both creations of jim starlin the
guy who started thanos in greek
mythology eros is the god of love and
sex and in the marvel comics he can
control the emotions of others he's kind
of a creeper a total horn dog which
makes casting the super likeable hairy
styles in this role just really works no
we should say at one point arrows was
put on trial for sexual assault defended
by she-hulk
in the mcu though really the guy is in
the turtle of the planet titan and
brother to the mad titan thanos the
second son of alars and if the mcu
sticks to the genealogy from the comics
alars was a brother to zuros athena's
father making her and arrow's first
cousin so uh maybe throttle back their
arrows this is the family room screw it
attach the jewelry it's best known as
aeros's companion and their hedonistic
lifestyle i guess you'd kind of say like
the rocket to a star lord but not
exactly originally pip was a foil to
adam warlock yes who is also coming into
the mcu soon he was a species called a
laxadasian
he was actually a prince who mutates
into this seder like troll who ends up
playing a pretty big role in the
infinity gauntlet storyline alongside
adam warlock by the way black roger was
a nemesis to arrows a big goofball who
attacked when arose's girlfriend heater
delight turned roger down and then
arrows with howlin wolf yes the famous
yeah
transformation powers these guys all
defeated rogers yeah it's supposed to be
crazy it was the 70s i mean if we
thought eternals was challenging formula
let's adapt that come on 70s comics
let's get horny ass hairy styles and
pictures doing all kinds of crazy things
yeah says me too doing people all over
the emcee so arrows having this
celestial beacon is just one example of
eternals from other planets in the mcu
free from celestial control and this
might tell us that thanos was acting
either in accordance or in defiance to
their celestial overlords actually
interesting nanos delayed the emergence
on earth so maybe thanos's plan to
reduce all of life in the universe by
half was actually his attempt to stop or
delay celestial seeds from hatching and
disrupt the celestial reproduction cycle
did nothing wrong but it's also
interesting how arose doesn't seem to
fear whatever celestial he is in touch
with so there may be other celestials
out there who oppose ereshim and may
give eros a chance to appeal to an even
higher power in order to free cersei
kingo and bastos so where did erosham
take them well it sounded like he
planned to assess their legal right to
claim earth's worthiness based on their
memories as kind of like a legal
transcript so yes he could be taking
them first to the world forge that he
showed cersei in the vision where
eternal memories of past lives are
stored but since he doesn't just you
know destroy them here airship may be
bound by cosmic laws that are set by a
higher authority so i believe he could
be taking them to the court of the
living tribunal marvel's ultimate judge
a character who was just teased in the
penultimate episode of loki so wherever
we see these characters next maybe thor
love and thunder maybe guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. i suspect that we may be
in store for a celestial trial before
the living tribunal with cersei as a
defendant and eros and pip as surprise
witnesses with their own celestial
representative arguing on cersei's
behalf i got to say my mind did not jump
to even a quarter
of any of these conclusions
but the main thing out of all that like
i would love to see the trial of the
cosmos that would be amazing to behold
that's something i've been wanting them
to do and i think having aeroship and
especially that tease definitely alludes
to that especially with the idea of what
thanos was actually doing is to go
against the celestials that he was
actually trying to do a good deed
because they do say that he prevented
the emergence is what's called yeah
he delayed the emergence why didn't they
interfere when thanos was doing all
those things and they could just do a
whole thing to completely answer that
right there the next movie will go in
search of simply answering that one
question especially with how some people
have walked away from this movie going
it feels like all those things with
thanos felt kind of inconsequential or
insignificant in comparison to
everything they're setting up here then
you would find out that no is actually
all tied in that's clever yeah if that
is the route and it seems likely
considering what thanos's roots are in
the comics and the fact that you have
star fox showing up in here now you
thought these things were weird i think
it's about to get a lot weirder now the
second post-credits scene centers around
dane whitman who gets sidelined for most
of the film aside from cersei giving him
a ring from the middle ages that bears
his family crest the raven emblem of the
black knight sprite and then talking
about the ebony blade and excalibur and
references to dane making peace with an
uncle in that his family history is
quote complicated in the marvel comics
dane whitman is one of the heroes to
carry the title of the black knight a
warrior with ancestral roots to sir
perseus scandia a contemporary of king
arthur and he's known for carrying the
badass sword of the ebony blade but now
in this scene he opens a box marked with
the raven emblem from his ring and on
the inner lid is carved the latin phrase
morse mihi lucrum which dane reads aloud
and it translates to death is my reward
and then dane works himself up to open
his box and inside is the ebony blade
which as he touches it has an organic
weave that reaches out to greet his
finger so this isn't just a sword it's
like a living weapon in the vein of
excalibur or maybe the sword carried by
gore the god butcher christian bale's
character in the upcoming thor for it
thor love and thunder which in the
comics was the same weapon that beheaded
the celestial nowhere perhaps in the mcu
the ebony blade has the same kind of
damage
but then my favorite part of this we
hear this voice behind dane are you sure
you're ready for that mr whitman now my
first thought was that this was jeffrey
wright the voice of uwatu the watcher
and what if there's love to suddenly
drop in on heroes as a voice from
nowhere just like this feeling it's not
gonna be now missions and i think the
black knight would make a pretty good
candidate for battle world and avengers
5 secret wars but listening to it more
closely i realized this is totally the
voice of mahershala ali confirmed as
blade in the mcu back at comic con 2019
when kevin feige first introduced the
eternals cast fandoms eric goldman
reports a quote from chloe zhao and from
kid harry potter
that is indeed
blade in this
holy crap
oh my god i've been sitting here for
days now like why do people think it's
fun
it's clearly not right it's the only
thing that would make sense oh whoa
that is so surprising damn it i saw some
people that were saying yeah marshall
and i'm like i don't think so guys guys
calm down and when we were in the
premiere when that scene came up there
was a big group of people all discussing
who that was some thought it was samuel
jackson we laughed and pointed and said
get the hell out idiots and then the
common consensus that everyone had was
well what if just ended and that's
probably that's jeffrey right that
sounds like jeffrey right it's probably
jeffrey right i thought that was a
no-brainer and then here we got chloe
chow coming out here and going yeah it's
a blade play play blade yeah it's
playing
here i am thinking jeffrey wright has
such a distinction
and now i'm like well i guess he must
sound just like marshall ollie better
brush up on what he sounds like holy
[ __ ] that is uh that is shocking i i
don't i don't know why i'm sorry we are
wrong we are wrong you've been proven
wrong peter mistaking a whole bunch of
different black voices the whole i know
i'm racist all of us are racist that's
what happened
everyone accused me of those rotten
tomatoes critics all right that's right
that's right critics are a whole
different whole different mind of people
and and they're also racist so blade and
dane whitman were both on a team called
mi13 a british agency set up to deal
with paranormal threats on this team
whitman realized that he was actually
wielding a fake ebony blade that was
forged by dracula blade's nemesis and
whitman's time on mi-13 is actually set
during secret invasion he uses this
weapon to slaughter scrolls and super
scrolls now vampires were teased earlier
in eternals by kingo actually when we
first met he thought i was a vampire and
he tried to stake me through the heart
we should also point out that it looked
like scrolls came up during arishim's
revelation of all the truths to cersei
but a bit of background on blatantly
cheese and loki's mother who was bitten
by a vampire mid-delivery making him
born half human and half vampire giving
him vampiric qualities and he begins
vampire hunting foes like dracula dick
and frost and then gets bitten by our
buddy morbius big wig for him a bite
that gave blade all the classic
strengths of vampires but none of the
weaknesses and he goes by the alias of
day walker so now it seems like dane's
next appearance and the mcu could be in
the blade film no release damn wow
potentially november 2023 or maybe even
sooner like in secret invasion
why not
at this point i'm just gonna say it's
all it's not actually his family's sword
the mythic ebony blade but an imposter
placed there by a vampire thus the
meaning of that latin phrase death is my
reward fitting for an immortal
bloodsucker long hunted by the church
since the middle ages now like dane i
was hoping for a weapon more useful in
slaying a celestial as that organic
texture on the weapon reminded me a lot
of all black the necker sword but it may
just be that marvel is sticking to
merely one direction
i'm sorry and back on earth teaming up
two black blades to slice up some
vampires or scrolls to whatever death is
more rewarding i do like the idea of
this isn't the way that you're
reintroducing blade at a bigger part of
the universe that's more than just yeah
he's been walking around new york
killing
vampires yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
have them come in what seems like maybe
a pivotal moment for a different
character and maybe that being the
launching point for a whole relationship
we're about to see like that could be
cool yeah especially like when you think
about how spider-man had a bunch of
standalone movies of being in new york
and then this was like here's what it
would be if spider-man was in the marvel
cinematic universe i like the approach
of doing that with blade on his first
outing of this is what blade would be
like in the marvel cinematic universe as
opposed to just rebooting a standalone
killing vampires in new york follow me
on instagram and twitter at ea boss new
rockstars and subscribe for breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
wow i've never been more wrong about
anything in my whole life
so many of us were convinced especially
because we had just finished what if
they're like oh they're finally tied
into the disney plot show
first time all right we didn't even need
to admit we were wrong
we never publicly said it was the
witcher no
we could have pretended the whole time
like we called it yeah you had to knew
it yeah we decided to maintain integrity
for you guys all right guys i'll leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
that bell keep a look out for our
eternal spoiler talk and hey let's do a
pic
now if there's anyone on our patreon
page who could be someone who haunts
vampires it's easily gotta be
deontay w tug punch fart box absolutely
what he would do is he would eat so much
garlic just consumed so much garlic and
that he would fart not uncontrollably
into a box
conceal the garlic scent in there when
he goes and attacks vampires he opens
the box
garlic spread kills them all
little jesus christ crucifixes pierce
through the veil of the garlic latching
onto themselves filled with silver
because this bottle can handle quite a
lot you disgusting pig you and that's
why i love that you've been part of our
patreon page for so long you've never
changed your name always leading for
amazing imaginative scenarios of what to
do with tongue punch fart boxing keep a
look out next month where we tie it in
to
the next light year trailer
the tongue buzz fart box
[Music]